would it be useful to maybe try to
explain from Oz Last Theorem sure it's
easy to do
[Laughter]
I'm an optimist I think I always think
that everything can be explained you
know even though I say that not
everything can be explained but in in
mathematics you know in within this
particular framework I think that I
always feel optimistic when people ask
me to explain something I always start
with the assumption that they will
understand yes you know
so let's try
ethereum
one of the jewels
sort of of mathematics of all time
a beautiful story also behind it Pierre
Verma a great French mathematician who
lived in the beginning of mostly worked
at the beginning of about 17th century
and uh he actually has to his credit a
number of important contributions but
the most famous is called firma's last
ethereum or return was a great ethereum
and the reason why it became so famous
is in part because he actually claimed
to have proved it himself and he did it
on a margin of a of a book that he was
reading which was a actually important
book by diafantos about equations with
coefficients and whole numbers
and he wrote on the margin literally
I this equation you know this problem
which I will explain in a moment
um I have solved it I have found a proof
but this margin is too small to contain
it
at some point I I give I was given a
public talk about this and I made it as
a joke I made a tweet in which I wrote
that I have proved this theorem but 280
characters are not enough and the kind
of customer admit sentences yeah so this
was 17th century Twitter style proof
okay but a lot of mathematicians took it
seriously because he had great
credibility he did did made did make
some major contributions
and the search was on so for 350 years
about
350 years
it remained
unproved with many people trying
and failing until in 1994
no in 1993 Andrew Wiles announced a
mathematician from Princeton University
announced the proof and it was very
exciting because he was one of the top
number theorists in the world
and unfortunately about a year later a
gap was found so that's exactly what we
were talking about earlier you have 99
of the proof this one little thing does
not quite connect and this nullifies the
whole thing even though well you could
say there's some interesting ideas but
it's not the same as actually having a
proof so he apparently was really
frustrated and he was really a lot of
people thought that it's going to be
another 100 years or whatever
and then luckily he was able to enlist
with with the help assistance with of
his a former student also great number
theorist Richard Taylor they were able
to do that one percent so to speak well
some people might say it maybe not one
but five percent or whatever but it
definitely was an important ingredient
but it was not he had a sort of like a
big new set of ideas and this one thing
didn't pan out they were able to close
it with Taylor and it finally was
published and I think was accepted and
refereed in 95 and since in is believed
to be correct
now uh what he proved actually was not
verma's theorem itself
but a certain statement which is called
shimurtaniam away conjecture named after
three mathematicians to Japanese
mathematicians and one French porn
mathematician who works and also at The
Institute for advanced studying in in in
Princeton
and it was my colleague at UC Berkeley
Ken ribbett who in the 80s connected the
two problems so this is how it often
Works in mathematics you want to prove
statement a
instead you prove that a is equivalent
to B
so after that if you can prove B this
would automatically imply that a is
correct so this is what happened here a
was forma's Last Theorem B was
simultaneous conjecture and that's what
Andrew Wiles and Richard Taylor really
proved so it requires to get to firma's
Last Theorem it requires that bridge
which was established by my colleague
Ken Ribbit at UC Burke so now what is
the statement of hermoslav's theorem
um let me start with Pythagoras since we
already talked about it let me start
with Pythagoras Theorem which describes
uh the right triangles so what is the
right triangle is a triangle in which
one of the angles is 90 degrees like
this so it has three sides the longer
side is called hypotenuse
and then there's two other sides so if
we denote the high points the lengths of
hypotenuse by Z and the two other sides
X and Y
then Z squared is equal to x squared
plus y squared
so that's the equation or x squared plus
y squared equals z squared
and it turns out this equation
has Solutions in natural numbers
main is actually infinitely many
solutions in natural numbers
for example if x is you take x equals 3
y equals 4 and Z equals 5.
then they solve this equation because 3
3 squared is nine
four squared is 16.
9 plus 16 25
and that's 5 squared
so x squared plus y squared equals z
squared is solved by x equals three y
equals four is equals five and there are
many other Solutions of that nature and
we should say that natural numbers are
whole numbers that are non-negative
that's right one two three four five six
and so on now what's sperma's Last
Theorem Firma asked what about what will
happen if we replace squares by cubes
for example so X Cube plus y Cube equals
z Cube
are there any solutions in
what do you call natural numbers
it turns out there are none
what about fourth powers
again none or it seems like none right
so that was the that was the statement
so the theorem says that the equation x
cubed plus y Cube equals e cubed has no
Solutions in natural numbers
uh remember natural means positive whole
numbers so of course there is a trivial
solution zero zero zeros so that this
works but you need all of them to be
positive
x to the fourth plus y to the fourth
equals z to the fourth also has no
Solutions
uh x to the fifth plus y to the fifth
equals z to the fifth no Solutions so
you kind of see the trend
x to the N plus y to the N plus equals z
to the N if n is greater than two
has no Solutions in natural numbers that
is a statement of therma's last year
deceptively simple as far as famous
theorems are concerned you don't need to
know anything beyond standard arithmetic
addition and multiplication of natural
numbers
that's why a lot of people
uh both
um Specialists and amateurs
try to prove it so because it's so easy
so telling so easy to formulate
so in fact I think Verma proved the case
of Cubes I think he did actually prove
some elsewhere in the case of Cubes but
so it remained like force there are
infinitely many cases right you have to
even if you prove it for cubes and for
fourth power and fifth then still there
is six sevens and so on the infinitely
many cases in which it has to be proved
and so you see
um the separate simple result took 350
years to prove
and you know but in a sense it's like
mathematicians you know you would think
mathematics is such a sterile profession
everybody's so serious you know almost
like we're all wearing like lab coats
and like take an elevator to the to the
every Tower and however look at all this
drama
look at all these dramas like we all
select drama we also have narratives we
also have our myths
here is a guy is the 16th century
mathematician or 17th century
mathematician who lives a note on the
margin and motivates others to find the
proof then how many cards were broken
that they believed that they found the
proof and then later it was realized
that the proof was incorrect and so on
and brings us to modern day and one last
attempt and reviles who is very serious
and respected and esteemed mathematician
announces the proof only to be faced
with the same reality of his hopes
dashed seemingly dashed and like there
is a mistake it doesn't work and then to
be able to recover a year later how much
drama in this one story it's amazing but
from what you understand for what you
know what was the process for him that
uh that is similar perhaps to your own
life of of of of walking along with the
problem for months
not years yes so he worked he has given
interviews about it afterwards so we
know that he described his process
that number one he did not want to tell
anybody because he was afraid that
people find out that he's working on it
because he's was such a top level
mathematician people would guess that he
has some idea that there is some idea so
you know
if you just know that somebody's has an
idea this already gives you a great
boost of confidence right so he didn't
want people to have that information so
he didn't tell anybody that he was
working on it number one be lonely
number two he worked on it for seven
years if I remember correctly by himself
and
then then he he thought he had it and he
was elated obviously he was you know
very happy and he announced it at the
conference I think it was in Cambridge
University or Oxford University in the
UK in 1993 I believe
so
you know
this
is really interesting because all of us
we can really all matters can relate to
this because I I remember very well my
first problem how I solved my first
problem
uh I described it in in love and math in
my book so uh it was I was how old was I
I was 18 years old I was a student in
Moscow
and I was just I just lucked out that I
was introduced to this great
mathematician since I you know I was not
studying at Moscow University because I
find semitism in the Soviet Union so I
was in this technical school but I was
lucky that I had a mathematician who
took me under his wing
and Dmitry Fox who actually
later came to the to the US and he's
still a professor at UC Davis
not so far from from me
uh so he gave me this problem and
it was rather technical so I will not
try to describe it but I do remember how
much uh effort you know the that
excitement but also kind of a fear what
if I don't have what it takes you know I
lost sleep so this was one one
consequence of this I for the first time
in my life I had trouble falling asleep
and this guy actually stayed for a
couple years afterwards so then it was
kind of like a wake-up call that I
should be to take care of myself not
work too late and so on so that was sort
of like that experience and I was lucky
that I was able to find a solution
number one within two months Maybe
and it was very it was surprising and it
was beautiful like it the answer was was
in terms of some something which seemed
to be from A Different World from a
different area of mathematics
so I was very happy but I do remember
this this moment when suddenly you see
that just like you in this case it was
literally I had to compile these
diagrams with what mathematicians call
Co homology groups and spectral
sequences and manually calculate some
some numbers and trying to discern some
system in it and suddenly I saw that how
they all were governed by this one uh
one one force so to speak one pattern
and that was absolutely wow so it's like
I mean what was it so you're sitting
there at a desk
actually you know I lived in a town
outside of Moscow so I used to take I
would take a train to Moscow so it's
what we call in Russia electric you know
like this electric train which was super
slow it took more than two hours to
cover that distance and I think that the
crucial Insight came when I was in this
and I just I was I had to contain myself
so I don't start screaming you know
because there were other passengers in
the car so I was sitting there and
staring at this paper so you know what I
remember that's what came to me I have
something now
which nobody else in the world has I
have a proof of first of all I did not
it was not just the proof like in the
case of Irma the statement is already
made that's why it's called conjecture
you know you make a statement you don't
have a proof yet then you try to prove
it in my case I did not know what the
answer would be there was a type of
question where the answer was unknown so
I had to find the answer and prove it
and the answer was very nice so nobody
knew as far as I could tell nobody knew
because my teacher told me that he
explored all the literature and this was
not known so this was
suddenly I felt that I was in possession
of this
now it was a little thing it was not
cured for cancer you know it was not
a large language model you know but it
was something undeniably real meaningful
and it was mine kind of you know like I
had it nobody else I cannot published it
I didn't even tell I hadn't even told
anybody and it is a very strange feeling
you know to have to have that were you
worried that this treasure could be
stolen
not at the time not at the time so later
on there were situations where I was
exposed to that those type of
experiences but at that time I didn't
think of that I was still this
starry-eyed kid you know who was just
obsessed with mathematics with his
Beauty and Discovery discovering those
beautiful facts beautiful results so I
didn't think about I didn't even think
that it could be possible that somebody
could steal it or whatever uh I just
wanted to share it with my teacher as
soon as possible you know and and he he
understood quickly and he's like yeah
good job you know